لما بلش وضع البلد يسوق فشفت انه الموضوع
الصيانه صار يمشي اكثر من البيع والشراء
لهيك انه خلص قررت انه يتعلم هذه المصلحه
الناس بشكل عام كانت اصلا يعني بدايه
الاحداث صارت كانت تصلح هلا وصلوا لمرحله
عم يبيعوا الاغراض الاساسيه بالبيت يعني
قبل شويه اجتني المراه والغساله انت شايفه
دور الشناتي تبع المدارس
[موسيقى]
في اشياء انا بستفيد فيها هون بهذا المحل
لانه بصراحه بالمولات ما بقى فينا نقدر
نجيب حتى الاسعار اختلفت لك يعني هون قد
ما فينا اا بنستفيد ااا بالقليل انه شغل
برا يعني
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الوضع ما فينا نشتري اول شيء جديد لانه كل
شيء جديد ما حتقدر تشتريه فمضطر نيجي على
الاشياء المستعمله اييي مثلا ادوات المطبخ
او
ادوات البيت كلها لمرحله انه العاب
الاولاد اللي بيتسلوا فيهن بيرفع عن نفسهم
نفسه
كل هذا العاب اولاد
[موسيقى]